hey guys Leanna gilja from Entertainment
Tonight here with the amazing Katrina
ball and Sam heughan we're gearing up
for outlander season two and so to
celebrate I think we should play a
little game of two truths and a lie
all right two truths and a lie Katrina
about your hidden talents I can say
hello in ten different languages I can
play the accordion and I'm pretty mean
this one's very easy any steps to take
before a longer but usually about
fourteen fifteen I think the accordion
that's definitely a truth oh you're very
school and the other one what was the
other one
oh ten different languages Japanese yes
Japanese Quechua German is suspicious
about this one so I'm gonna go for the
ten languages
I imagine you are a good long jumper you
have long legs
yes yeah in your high heels in height in
high school high school yeah good tell
us two truths and a lie about your
childhood this as I was brought up
pesco vegetarian I didn't eat meat until
I was the age of 23 my second I had a
black-and-white television that you have
to tune in and didn't get a color
television until I was 20 my third was I
had a miserable childhood was brought up
by hippies but I don't think it was
miserable
I can imagine that you probably were
pesco vegetarian for quite a while
23 I feel like you would have rebelled
in those shackles and had a steak
mmm in a rat what was your other one oh
the TV I believe that actually I am also
a child of parents who had weird things
with TV so we didn't have TV for a long
time I knew that all right the last one
you were raised by the bees but it
wasn't miserable that's correct
well thank you guys so much for spilling
two truths and a lie
and for more information on Outlander
season to keep it locked to stars calm